hey youtubers is Charlie so in my Game
of Thrones episode 7 video I asked you
to submit all of your questions so I
picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question also big
congratulations to Leslie Hernandez you
are this week's random giveaway winner
you win a $20 Amazon gift card I'll be
reaching out to you on your channel for
details if you're finding me for the
first time I do Q&A is like this for all
my biggest stuff like Game of Thrones
and anything else you guys just want to
spend more time talking about based on
the videos that I do so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and feel
free to leave me suggestions for future
bonus videos after I do questions I'll
talk a little bit about what my schedule
is gonna be like this week it's gonna be
just a little bit weird but let's talk
about some moondoor so careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet but question number one
Sarah asks what do you think Melisandre
will do with Stannis's daughter I don't
remember that from the books so I think
that she's just gonna try and sacrifice
Shireen to gain some sort of power it
seems like her using royal blood makes
her spells much more powerful like
whenever she used Stannis to make the
shadow baby she probably couldn't have
done that with any normal person it had
to be someone with royal blood the show
doesn't really explain why only that
royal blood is special in the eyes of
the red god the way I think about it is
like a cleric prays to their God and
their God grants them power for a short
amount of time I kind of think that's
what the relationship between Melisandre
Thoreau's and the red God is it's not
like sorcery where you just get your
powers from a mystical place or through
the use of spells and incantations as
for what kind of spell she's going to
try and cast I think she's just gonna
try and make their army stronger push in
number 2 pizza Dalek asks that's an
awesome name I think Littlefinger kissed
Sansa because he knew Lysa was watching
and it was all part of some big scheme
so you were part right he kissed her for
a whole bunch of reasons partly because
he was working a long con to get rid of
Lysa and she was just a means to an end
Sansa was the kiss but he also has
really conflicted feelings about her he
said it all in the speech there he kind
of laid it out she is for him several
things the daughter he never had and a
much more beautiful version of the only
woman he ever loved so he's part
sentimental part creeper kind of all
things at the same time as for how Sansa
feel
about all this I'd say she's just
shocked and doesn't know what the hell's
going on
remember she's still shedding a lot of
her innocence she's still kind of
learning to be a pessimist like everyone
else on the show so she has no idea
what's going on with Littlefinger's plan
to get rid of Lysa
question number three Kirsten Knightley
asks why did Daenerys let the Masters
keep their power and wealth yeah she
really made it seem like she just
crucified X number of masters for the X
number of slaves that they killed but I
think she's just giving them a choice I
think the show was going to explain a
little bit more about her relationship
with the rest of the slaving families in
Mereen she's currently the power in the
city so a lot of them are just sucking
up to her like sycophants and Kings
Landing do with the Iron Throne she
really did kill a lot of them though but
all of the slaving families have sons
like hizdahr so killing their fathers
just means the sons will take over so if
she really wanted to get rid of slaving
completely she'd have to kill all the
families like everyone in the family
which is way more people and as much of
a badass as she is I don't think she's
prepared to murder that many people
she's just giving them the choice you
know except my new terms or die in my
new world like she said in the episode
question number 4 rel laronne asks do
you think we'll see Kendra this season I
certainly hope so there was actually
something Joe Dempsie the actor that
plays Gendry posted on Twitter he was
just thinking you know everyone for all
the awesome people he got to work with
this year and one of them was Maisie
Williams I think it's okay to assume he
was talking about Game of Thrones
because the only other project on Maisie
Williams IMDB page does not list Joe
Dempsie as a cast member so it's more
likely that he just has a greatly
reduced role remember the last time we
saw him he was rowing for King's Landing
from Dragonstone so it's possible that
he could have been picked up by a ship
or he really will make it back to King's
Landing his character is one of the ones
they've changed the most from the book
so I don't want to make too many
predictions but I do think we'll see him
at least a little bit before the end of
the season question number 5
bloody desires asks did Brienne choose
to follow pod suggestion about Sansa
being with her aunt yes it was really
subtle so it's kind of hard to tell but
they are headed for the Vale I don't
think it will be as simple as them just
finding Sansa that the Vale that seems
too nice of an ending for Game of
Thrones so I'm planning on something
really really bad happening on their
journey either they'll run into the
Brotherhood and someone dies poor they
run into Arion
found and someone dies either way it's
Game of Thrones so someone's probably
gonna die question number six
Declan asks could you explain who
Lolly's Stokeworth is so I did see a
bunch of people asking about lollies in
the comments because she was a character
from the books that was cut out of
season two she's a minor character from
King's Landing in season two when all
the peasants righted and tried to kill
Joffrey in the books her character is
brutalized by the mob
she's from a noble house but after the
mob attack no one wants to marry her
she's like a young person so cut to
Tyrians trial this season
Cersei tries to win over everyone in
when she comes to bran she offers him a
title in a castle and a marriage to
lolis so bran is marrying into money and
as you can see he's not really picky
about women so the show basically just
included her as like a minor footnote
because in the books bran really does
end up marrying lollies like that's how
he gets his title question number seven
Nikolas asks what was the mountain doing
with all those guys he was just
executing them for petty crimes like
normally you would just lock people up
the mountain was just slaughtering them
like cattle though the reason it's so
terrible is because they probably just
committed really minor crimes the
mountain is like a crazier version of
Sir Ilyn Payne
Payne is the Kings executioner but he
has scruples the mountain is who you
call whenever you want someone killed no
questions asked he's like a fixer for
Tywin Lannister he just makes problems
go away no questions asked so they also
wanted to show just how dangerous he is
question number 8 Nathan asks why do
lisent our son seem to have years of
interbreeding in their blood so that's
actually kind of funny because even in
real life all Royals have like a certain
minor level of interbreeding going on
because there's not that many Royals to
pick from if you want to get married and
you want to keep your blood very royal
like over the course of centuries all
the royal families everywhere end up
being at least a little bit related to
each other at a blood level but Lysa is
a start she's not really born of incest
or anything and she wasn't related to
Jon Arryn when they were married so
technically Robin isn't a twincest baby
like Joffrey he's just super nutters in
the books Tyrion actually describes Lysa
as being touched as then she's just
super crazy in the head which is why I
think Littlefinger has had such an easy
time manipulating her over the years
although I'm sure he has had
role in making her even crazier like
he's pushed her over the edge literally
this time question number nine
Ashly asks could you explain Ober and
speech about baby Tyrion more so Tyrion
is several years younger than Oberyn
Jaime and Cersei like Oberyn Jaime and
Cersei are all about the same age so
whenever they were all really young and
Tyrion was in the process of being born
Oberyn just happened to be visiting
Casterly Rock while they were on their
way Taryn was born and his mother died
so everyone at Casterly Rock
including Cersei started telling stories
about Tyrion being a monster and killing
their mother they don't really explain
Circe's thought processes a lot other
than she decides to put all of her
negative feelings about her mother dying
on Terra and she just blames him Jaime
does not so Oberyn goes to see Tyrion in
his cradle and just like Jamie decides
that Tyrion is not a monster at all he's
just a little baby so they're just
trying to show how Oberyn has compassion
where Cersei does not question number 10
Nick asks do you think that brand would
ever be able to warg into one of
Daenerys dragons so they don't explain
the science of worrying too much but
they imply that it has a lot to do with
the mental fortitude of the vessel so it
would be a lot harder for bran to work
into a person of like normal
intelligence as opposed to hoarder who
has a much more primitive brain so it
all depends on how smart Daenerys is
dragons are they seem like there are a
lot more powerful than dire wolves so I
think bran would have to get a lot more
powerful like learning to use the force
more as a Jedi you know you have to go
through Jedi training before you can
fight the Emperor and Vader you know
just because he can warg does any
meetings automatically an expert at it
and one last bonus question Bombay theme
asks what did Daenerys mean whenever she
told Jorah to tell Daario that he
changed her mind so originally Daenerys
was gonna have Daario execute all of the
wise masters but Jorah counseled her
saying that the new followers the new
slaves that she had taken on would just
view that as more brutality and they
would rise up against her so his idea
was to at least give them the choice to
accept Daenerys his terms and Daenerys
was kind of throwing him a bone by
telling her to tell Daario that he had
changed her mind I think she feels a
little bit guilty about favoring Daario
now especially now that she's having sex
with him whenever Jorah has been so
loyal to her for so long
so she's just kind
showing him that she hasn't forgotten
about him completely so thank you so
much everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do
remember there is no new episode this
next weekend but I'll be doing a bonus
video anyway be sure to subscribe to get
it
also if you guys want I'll do another
Q&A - just let me know in the comments I
will be traveling from Thursday through
Sunday so I'll probably only post like
one video day each of those days but
I'll be posting updates on social so
links for all those accounts in the
description below right now you can
actually click here to get my episode 7
video and you can click here to learn
all about the wildlings thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you